here with me is our defense and security
analyst michael clark to talk us through
the day's developments and michael first
of all the russians have proposed some
humanitarian corridors to try to get
civilians out and yet the ukrainians are
rejecting them why is that i'll mock
them up as you talk well they don't seem
terribly realistic i mean these
humanitarian corridors are to take
civilians into russian areas or across
the border into belarus or russia um
they would have to stay open a long time
to get significant numbers of people out
of big cities and the ukrainians have
this sense as a lot of us a lot of us do
that if they do open humanitarian
corridors the russians would then say
afterwards well okay everyone who's now
in the city is a competent you've had a
chance to leave you haven't left so now
we're coming in so there's a degree of
propaganda about all of this which the
british minister of defense thinks is
just a ploy to distract attention okay
so let's take a look then at a map of
the south of the country now because
attacks by the russians are continuing
around the main cities aren't they let's
start with odessa shall we because this
is seen as being crucial for the
russians why is it so important and what
kind of progress are they making big an
important city it controls the economy
of of ukraine it's access to the black
sea all the grain and the bulk products
that they trade which are very important
to them and to the rest of the world and
all go through odessa and uh churner
mosque which is just south of odessa at
the moment the russians are fighting at
uh mikalev they've been thrown back once
from nicolet which is just to the east
of odessa if they get through mikolav
then odessa will present quite a
military challenge to them they're
digging in there for what could be a big
siege
and obviously really important for the
russians they really want that city they
don't have to take odessa if they're
going to create this corridor and get
control of ukraine's economy okay let's
take a look at her song meanwhile this
is the one main city that's under
russian control isn't it but can they
hang on to it
they can hang on to it because it's
they've got the area around it but
they're not really in control of kershaw
all of the information coming out is
that the russians are confined to
barracks more or less life is going on
relatively normally in kirsh and it's
not doing much good controlling that
city even though it's quite an important
city in terms of the rest of the the
area of southern ukraine and what about
mario paul because that's the other big
city that's being targeted and we have
got troops surrounding it haven't we at
the moment and is that the kind of
strategy that we're going to see from
the russians the surrounding of cities i
think it could be the the aggregate of
mario paul goes on it's surrounded it's
cut off no water no electricity food is
running short no humanitarian convoys in
or out and that is the model which the
russians may be following in other
cities as well well yes and would you
say that's the case for kiev if we take
a look at the north of the country now
we have got this big convoy so what's
the latest on that the convoy hasn't
moved for six days so it's still stuck
uh russian forces coming in from the
area of chernohith and sumi are moving
in from the uh the northeast so kiev
will be surrounded in the coming days
whether the russians will adopt the
mario pole tactics in kiev which will be
a huge
affront to humanity
we will have to see